she was nasty man there's a lot of a
mixed Jagger 15 million 25 million he
got off flight bro make jack cuz
remember he [ __ ] married in Jamaica
and he was like a Puerto Rican priests
on his day off so he knew it going in
cuz Mick jogging giving you dick I think
that was Jerry whose wife number two
who's this that's Bianca Jagger the
first one the first yeah you know first
one he had to pay the second why he's
like listen we're gonna work around this
left oh yeah he never [ __ ] around that
guy he before he was in under stones
again Jamie what's the school he went to
he well I don't make me say something
wrong
he went to the school of whales or
something for business he's all about
the cheddar it's for the last 15 years
he's just been impregnating women all
over the country and cutting him a check
and saying you know London School of
Economics yeah when it comes to bro when
it comes to admit there's stories that
you hear that you like no he didn't
like no he did not do you see a Joe
Rogan do you ever seen his rehearsal
things do you ever see any of his video
do you follow him at all I follow him
yeah you see any of the videos that he
does of him working out in the
afternoons essentially his art man like
you dance he's still like Michael
Jackson what's that stuff that guy does
not [ __ ] around now and I still remember
one particular story where he got the
boulder they played there where the
boulder Buffalo was with a college place
he walked in and he knows what's wrong
with those seats and they were like well
mr. Jagger they're behind the stage
[ __ ] you better get the sellin cuz I
ain't taking the stage until those
[ __ ] are sold out I sold the
tickets behind the stage Mick Jagger's
brutal they could pay for my ass I could
pay for my ass Mick Jagger's brutal
problem he's brutal and that was back
before they had those giant screens
there was no this is this is 88 they
didn't have those giant screens this is
88 87 they don't give a [ __ ] they didn't
have those big LCDs we could see them
like if you go see like say Drake
and he's at a theater and around and
like you see his butt right you're gonna
see his face on giant screens all around
you he'll see it you know if you go to
see like a real popular person and
there's a lot of people playing in the
round you know jack is an interesting
guy I don't think he's like very tight
watch this is Jesus mmm tight you know
he's just like how much time as you have
left though I mean he's like 76 right no
72 maybe 72 well 75 he's a 75 how much
time you got left if he came you're
lucky everything goes great you got 25
years but those last 25 are rough not
what he's got cuz he could just lay
there all day have young girls massage
and he's Mick Jagger though they could
just blow all this little nuts up and
sing [ __ ] he's probably getting blood
transfusions every day ya know he takes
good care he's the back he's the
backbone of the organization and just to
think that Keith Richards is still alive
and kicking and there's people out there
doing Crossfit and didn't Keith Richards
write a book where he's kind of shitty
about Mick Jagger he just told talk [ __ ]
about each other that's how they sell
books dogs yeah I know that's how they
said Mick Jagger probably called them
and said do this do this how the truth
[ __ ] it give me 10% and when that one I
mean when I watch those little rehearsal
tapes look at his fingers look at those
fingers we're looking at a Keith
Richards Keith Richards fingers is every
knuckle is swollen to the point it's
like double the size he looks like he's
got Megaton Diaz his hands he's like a
jujitsu guy you ever seen Megaton Diaz's
hands yeah did big [ __ ] Kenzi Dern's
dad the girl who wrote that made that
video yeah Larry like that
after you but her dad Megaton Diaz
jujitsu legend all his life he's done
the gay guys who do the gay all the time
they developed real bad arthritis in
their hands and their joints swell up
like crazy
see if you find Megaton Diaz's hands
that's not a good picture that's but
there's some pictures of his knuckles
they're there they're crazy they're all
[ __ ] up and twisted like yeah these
tell a little bit there there you go
zoom in on I didn't know he was McKenzie
Durin's day yeah her dad is a [ __ ]
legend look sue me as much as I could go
oh that's as much as he goes we see see
how [ __ ] flamed out those knuckles are
guys have done the game their whole life
and they're always grabbing and holding
on for the gig they get that yeah that's
okay we get the point but that that's
what Keith Richards fingers look like
like he's secretly doing jiu-jitsu on
the sly that's 40 years of playing yes
man that is crazy
that's guitar playing 40 years 50 years
meanwhile he looks just as good as Mick
Jagger he's doing blow everyday eating
cockroaches he looks as good as Mick
Jagger
look look great I don't think he looks
is I think Mick Jagger looks [ __ ]
sensational but he doesn't in the face
if you look at the two of them in the
face make that picture bigger Jeremy
look at them in the face
Mick Jagger looks older but that's just
it's hard to tell because Keith Richards
is smiling we should go I would love to
see me Jagger still pull 21 year olds
out of the audience I bet they feel so
weird when he [ __ ] him it must feel so
weird like you want to do it leave I was
a girl I was 20 years old I would [ __ ]
Mick Jagger just for the story but when
he climbs on top of you and you smelled
death you smell it coming out of his
pores he's not selves you smell
misfiring cells all over the place don't
send me old people didn't look like that
70 oh now but we're not going on the
road they weren't dancing like down on
tauron like that that's something that
you have to and this is a new thing it's
a new to all these but first of all all
these bands that are going on or in this
if I how about somebody called me the
other day they're like hey man I'm
thinking about doing something New
Year's Eve downtown you
no I hate New Year's Eve right I hate
downtown even more [ __ ] Ozzy
Osbourne's do in the forum New Year's
Eve classy on the Western forum the only
forum I [ __ ] know in LA in Inglewood
yeah with Rob Zombie and Marilyn Manson
Oh walking just and I'm sitting there
going seven years old and he's doing New
Year's Eve at the [ __ ] forgot you
probably got to his wife probably tells
him [ __ ] out of the house go make memory